all right
so
welcome everyone to our bosear unity
workshop
my name is philippe baba i'm a senior
developer advocate at bose so what that
means basically is i work with
developers
enabling them to build experiences for
our platform i host workshops we do game
jams hackathons also public speaking on
behalf of the platform and if you do end
up like building something
with the bosear unity sdk specifically
i'm on the unity side you'll most likely
be talking to me and i'll be you know
helping you get your idea and your
product out there and you know
trying to bring those on board to to
help you out with that as much as
possible so i am your voice when it
comes to these things
um
so i'm just going to talk a little bit
briefly about what is bose they are some
of you may already know or not but i'm
just going to get into it
so
we have a new concept called audio
augmented reality now many of you
probably already heard about augmented
reality first thing you probably think
about is you know hololens or ar kit
arcore
magic leap stuff like that so we are
actually audio first augmented reality
now what that means is
think like spatial audio for example um
where you have sounds placed in space
around you and you're kind of like
virtually hearing it spatially so what
enables us to do audio augmented reality
are these sensors that are located in
each of these bozear wearables you all
have a pair of frames but then we also
have our headphones as well which have
the same sets of sensors in them those
sensors are an accelerometer which
allows you to get impulse and you know
sudden movements
gyroscope which tracks rotation so
typically what we use the gyro for is to
track the user's head orientation and
magnetometer which is basically a
compass and we use that for our
navigation apps so if you know the gps
position of a user based on their phone
and if you use the magnetic heading from
where their head is actually like
pointing at you can kind of know what
they're looking at like on the map
pretty accurately actually
so we have gestures as well on our
devices so the frame specifically have
an input gesture here on the right side
it's a double tap
so it's not a specific like touch
sensitive sensor it's actually based on
the accelerometer so it's like the
little impulse
tap
and the tap actually works from from any
side but it's recommended to do it from
the right side because that's where the
sensor kit is
we also have custom gestures that we
actually encourage our developers to
kind of explore so and it's a mixture of
the other sensors so a custom gesture
would be something like uh
you're creating an experience until you
look up and you look up and then you
track that rotation change that would be
a custom gesture
i know some some of the games that have
been built sometimes it tells you to
duck and there's a bullet flying over
you or something like that so that that
would be a custom gesture
so
heads up hands-free is one of the models
that we have um so the idea behind heads
up hands-free is a lot of the
applications today whether they're ar or
just standard mobile applications you're
always staring at your phone you're
always walking around you know you're an
eczema crane because you're always
looking down at your phone
the whole idea behind heads up
hands-free is that we want to create
applications that you don't have to
stare at your phone the input is the
wearable and the output also goes
through the wearable so you don't
actually have to look at a screen for
most of these activities so i'll give
you an example um
let's say uh like navigate for example
what it does is
it knows your gps location based on the
mobile device and it knows you're
heading based on where you're looking
with the magnetometer so what they can
do is they can tell okay you're looking
at this restaurant for example or this
cafe you double tap the input gesture
and it'll actually pull a yelp review
so now think about the non-heads-up
hands-free way of pulling up a yelp
review what are you doing you're most
likely googling the name you know or
you're typing in the street address but
it requires you to pull out your phone
launch the app
find a name type it in or the address or
or on the pin on the map and then you
get to that yelp review now that's it
takes you out of what you're doing um so
if you want to look up like five or six
restaurants walking down the street
you're basically probably staring at
your phone for like 15 minutes the idea
behind heads up hands-free is you just
walk by a place tap you get the
information you move on no no phone
required at least not looking at it
um now
it's it's a really cool concept i think
um and a bunch of our apps kind of like
use that as its guiding principle it's
not a must but it's it's kind of like a
design philosophy and
some of the developers have been really
clever about about implementing it
so the way that it works is the sensors
actually the data gets sent to the
mobile app so the wearable has to work
with the mobile phone so ios or android
um and that that goes for the frames and
the headphones as well
so some of the products that work with
it are like the frames for example which
you all have here i'm going to show just
a little brief what kind of like intro
and frames
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
so frames were actually a concept that
came out of our san francisco office so
it's a very different kind of idea
behind it
i personally think it's a super cool
idea
i think frames are really great like
outdoor wearable
it's great while you're biking for
example when you don't want to kind of
be interrupted um if you don't you don't
want to
get a call you can just pick up
straight through the frames you don't
have to pull out your phone or you can
do turn-by-turn navigation again you
don't have to like be mounting your
phone putting like a waterproof case or
whatever you just have your frames on
also if that doesn't plug up your ears
it's open your audio so you can still
hear the sounds of the street around you
and it's not unsafe in that way like
wearing like noise cancelling headphones
while biking for example
uh i just realized i gotta like do this
quick time thing
might be cut there
there we go
next up
qc35 twos now this product you might be
more familiar with you've probably seen
people wearing these um usually maybe on
an airplane
so this is like the classic um
nice cancelling headphone which also has
boseaw sensors in it and a lot of people
actually don't know that so
i think i believe it's
all the models after october of 2018
were were manufactured with the bosear
sensors in it
and then the nc 700s which are these so
these are the the brand new noise
cancelling headphones that just came out
uh i get asked like what's the
difference between the qcs and the ncs
there's a few obviously there's a
there's a redesign it looks a lot more
modern it has a little bit more kind of
like a sleek aesthetic i kind of think
that the the qc35s have a very kind of
like uh dad road trip kind of look to
them especially the gray ones um but
yeah it's a brand new redesign and
one of the main um upgrades i'd say is
the microphone so for conference calling
it actually has a noise cancelling
microphone because it has eight beam
forming mics so it can actually pick up
your voice as opposed to the to the
environment so
i found it really good in like loud
environments they've actually done
like comparison tests like in a loud
environment and you can barely hear
anything in the background while you
know while you're talking with them so
um i personally really like that because
i do a lot of conference calls and
sometimes noisy environments
um
there's a little promo video associated
with that too if you want to see
and these were the first
the first product that was kind of
the first bose product that kind of
has been marketed with the bose ar
features in it
so the whole idea behind the nc's is
again the heads up hands-free
is
[Music]
[Music]
so i don't know if you saw him doing it
in a video but there's a little
capacitive touch screen here on the side
so it's not touch screen
it's a touch
surface yeah and um it's uh yeah you can
do volume up and down
skip track or or go back and then
there's also a touch and hold which you
can actually
um get as a gesture inside bose ar so
when you're building your app so again
the whole idea is
you're not pulling out your phone you
have your wearable your your ar enabled
wearable which is your headphones which
you carry around with you if you're like
me i carry around my headphones
everywhere so you know you can talk to
your to your google assistant or to siri
through it receive messages it'll
actually read out the messages too so
the whole again the whole idea is to
have this wearable be pretty much like
your main input and output device for
your daily just you know mobile uses
so
one of our projections that we're going
to have 1 million ar devices in 2019
across all three of the products that i
just showed you now that's actually
really huge because
um
most are
is is
single kind of purpose ar it's like you
if you get a hololens it's more
enterprise you're not really going to be
wearing it out on the bus
you know or magically same thing you
know they only work in certain
environments you know it can't be in
bright sunlight and ar typically is
is a very niche thing that's found in in
specific places for specific use cases
but the idea behind bozear is that these
wearables are actually being worn by
people every day already just for their
regular life to listen to music to do
their conference calls but now we have
this ar platform built into it as well
and developers can actually leverage a
very big install base because there's
there's a lot of these devices out there
and they're constantly being sold and
the you know the user base is growing
and they're going to be looking for for
bose ar-enabled apps what can i run on
these new headphones that i just bought
um so we have an ios and android native
sdk and then we also have a unity plugin
which is what we're going to be using
today which actually works with both ios
and android
so i'm just going to go into a few of
the use cases a few of the apps that are
here that might be a little bit
inspiring so you can kind of get an idea
what people are doing um so autocast is
is a really cool concept behind like um
how you can for example let's say you're
a music festival
um
they could set up a tour where you
actually hear these audio pings so if
there's like a point of interest as
you're walking by you'll just hear like
a spatial audio pane and it's very
unintrusive it's not like it's yelling
at you like hey there's a thing here
it's just kind of like it's a ping and
then if you look at that ping you can
actually double tap to enter it and
it'll tell you oh this is um you know
this stage or maybe if you're doing like
a historical tour i'll tell you this is
this landmark would you like to enter
this tour and then you you enter it and
then you can go and actually explore and
it'll it'll kind of like tell you what
what these environments are
uh walk is kind of a similar concept
also to taylorcast navigate and never
got explained earlier it's kind of like
you're using the gesture to yelp things
basically
so it's really cool to kind of like not
bring you out of your travel experience
you're just kind of like walking and
exploring and getting the information
you need without again staring at your
phone
so all these kind of use
initially in the sensors but i said so
use the gps from the mobile device and
then use the magnetic heading from the
wearable and what's really cool about
using magnetic heading from the frames
people always wear their sunglasses
perpendicular you know it's not like
your phone where the magnetometer
sometimes you ever use the map and
you're trying to look at the compass on
the map and it's
opposite or it's not very accurate you
gotta like do this and you gotta like
recalibrate your phone so with the
frames it's actually a lot better
because you're not you're never really
putting that in like a wrong direction
it's always kind of like
facing perpendicular so it's it's really
good to get the heading
um sport and wellness so another use
case is somebody sport apps so golfshot
is actually a really great example uh
people wear frames
when they're off out on the golf course
it's sunglasses they might be listening
to music as well so it's a perfect fit
so golfshot is an already established
app
um that golfers use to get information
about about their shot you know stored
game details i'm not much of a golfer so
i don't really know like all the details
but i do know that uh they have a
beaujar enabled features that actually
allow you to measure things like
distance to to the next hole and again
without having to pull out your phone
and typing in some information it uses
all the data from the sensors and from
the mobile device it knows where you are
and knows what course you're on and then
you can kind of have this seamless
experience again without pulling out
your phone you're just already wearing
sunglasses because you're playing golf
and it's sunny and you know
yeah i i hope that makes sense
so new balance i think is is a really
cool one this is a demo um so they kind
of created like more of a uh like a
workout app it's kind of like a
motivational workout app where it'll
count your sets and reps so think like
you're doing sit-ups and you're actually
doing that custom gesture and you're
counting how many sit-ups you did and it
gives you like positive feedback oh
you're doing great two more you know or
something like that um so again
how if you weren't doing heads-up
hands-free
you know maybe you'd be checking your
phone to see how many you've done or you
know there's really no way to kind of
do it seamlessly unless you're kind of
wearing a little extra piece of sensors
on you
headspace is also a demo and this is
actually
is getting a big revamp
but
the idea behind this is it's a
meditation app so it's a perfect fit for
things like spatial audio they even have
a little bit of an exercise you kind of
like stretch your neck and then again
it's using kind of like the the sensors
in the wearable to actually be able to
tell if you did your your neck stretch
and when you did your next stretch and
then it kind of has a soothing voice
it's like all right so now we're going
to close our eyes and you know
and it starts to play like a little
soundscape and it helps you kind of like
meditate um another idea i heard brought
up is
you could actually check someone's
posture so if someone's falling asleep
you can kind of like slightly ping them
to wake up you know so things like that
um
like i said developers have been really
creative with it and then music of
course um
i think music is is one of the best use
cases because i think spatial audio
which is what today's workshop is mainly
going to be about is a very unexplored
area of of music or sound in general um
and bojar is a perfect fit for spatial
audio especially because of the sensors
that i was just mentioning um because
you know the head orientation you can
actually simulate spatial audio just
between the two stereo speakers you can
actually blend the sound between based
on where where your head is looking so
radar is a great example of this a radar
is an app built by bose
which actually connects to something
that's called creator tool that's
currently in development it's in it's
enclosed beta but the idea here is that
radar is going to be kind of like a
almost like a marketplace like area
where you can browse
lots of different spatial audio
experiences and they're going to be tied
to certain areas like on the map so
maybe if you're
in a certain place there's certain
spatial audio experiences that wouldn't
be
in some other place and it can do things
like it could ping you when you enter
let's say some park and maybe there's a
spatial audio experience tied to that
park and it'll you know you'll be able
to enter it if you just kind of have the
app running in the background
uh traverse is a cool example of
a mixture between our api and existing
ar apis i think they're using ar kit and
what it actually allows you to do is
it's kind of like
you're you're in the middle of a concert
and you're hearing like the different
instruments playing around you so what
you can actually do is while you're
holding your phone up you can actually
kind of like close your eyes just walk
around the room and you're actually
exploring all the different instruments
that are on you can walk up to the
singer you can walk up to the piano and
it's using ar kit to do positional
tracking and uh bossier for for spatial
audio and your head orientation so it's
actually using
both the phone's positional and the
head's rotational tracking and it knows
between the two and it kind of simulates
as if you're actually in
the middle of
a band or you know a concert that's
playing um iheart radio is is a cool
demo app i'd say uh
it's basically
another take on like how you can um tune
into different radio channels so instead
of pulling out your phone and and
seeking you're actually using your head
orientation and you're kind of like your
head's the tuner and then when you like
something you just kind of like double
tap it and you go into it and then you
can pull out of it at any time and tune
into something else and if you you get a
little preview and you like it you tap
into it and you're listening to it
without having to like look at oh
i'm 22.3 fm or whatever you're just kind
of like listening to it
um
now games uh is predominantly like in in
the realm of our unity sdk so we have
some cool games that have been built the
the three that i have up here are what i
would call representative experiences so
we actually have a lot more games that
have been built especially this year um
and i'll show you actually some videos
of the games to kind of like get
inspired so all these games are actually
out
so you can download them on the app
store um if you know if you have a bose
ar enabled wearable
uh and
like i said they're representative
experiences meaning that i believe these
developers uh kind of like created some
design patterns out of these they were
one of the first to make games for it
and i think these three are are kind of
like in their own category so overheard
it's a really funny game you basically
play as an englishman that's taunted by
french men
it castles at night it's very kind of
like monty python s
funny accents the voice acting is
hilarious and what you do is you use
your head as like a catapult and your
head orientation like this and you
double tap and you basically launch cows
into into these castles and you kind of
hear them move and you're like and it's
all spatial so you're kind of listening
for where they're at and when you're
turning your head you hear the castle's
over there and then they're the
frenchmen are like taunting you like oh
i bet you can't hit you know the broad
side of a barn or whatever my you know
i'm not going to try to do the accent
but you should hear it it's it it's
pretty hilarious um
and uh it's a great example of it's it's
kind of like using the spatial audio and
using
your
head orientation as like the controller
basically
so comrade is a cool uh design pattern
so it's basically like a
spy novel
um and it's it's a choose your own kind
of like adventure spy novel so you can
actually make decisions
in the story so the story goes on and
there's you know yes and no kind of like
decision trees that you go through and
at some point i think you have to duck
and dodge a bullet
um and it's got this whole ai theme to
it and the ai is talking to you and you
know you're making decisions and you
kind of change the outcome of the story
so that's a pretty popular design
pattern
and i one that i'm a huge fan of i love
choose your own adventure games and i
think that the medium is perfect for it
um instead of just doing yes or no on
the screen you can actually do yes and
no by nodding
you know and shaking your head so that's
that's it's very immersive when you get
asked the question and you're like yes
and then it kind of like goes on um dead
drop desperado is a multiplayer game uh
it's like a local multiplayer game so
what i actually really like about this
one is
it's got a little bit of a party game
kind of uh aesthetic to it so
you play with a friend and you
one of you holds the mobile phone and
the other one gets handed off like the
the wearable so let's say the headphones
and what happens is
he's standing in front of you and you
shoot bullets at your friend and your
friend is trying to dodge the bullets by
listening to where they're coming from
using this facial audio and you're kind
of like leaning left to right like that
and then it gets switched off and then
you're the one is dodging and he's the
one that's shooting and then in the end
there's kind of like a score tally and
it's like a leader board and it's kind
of like has a little bit of a
competitive aspect to it what i
personally like is that you could
let's say you know you
you have your headphones and you know
you want to show someone something cool
on them you can just kind of like hand
off the headphones and now now it's this
multiplayer interaction so you have the
headphones i have the phone and you
switch it up and it's it's also a little
bit competitive with the leaderboard and
such so
like i said like representative
experiences um
you're definitely not limited to these
design patterns we're actually excited
to see what our developers kind of come
up with and there's always like you know
cool stuff that the people come up with
and i just wanted to show you a little
bit um so we have this video that was
produced so we've hosted a bunch of game
jams this year and uh this is like one
of the first
game jams that we hosted and you know
these games that i just showed you were
actually built at it so i'll just i'll
go ahead and show you so this is from
our play crafting partnership uh play
crafting is like a
small like kind of like game developer
collective but plus they also kind of
like host events like play nyc and they
you know bring developers
um they teach unity classes and uh they
just have a general kind of like game
developer community across the country
so we've kind of partnered with them to
have some of these uh bozair game jams
and yeah i'll just show you the video
we're here this weekend
and we're doing a game jam with their
new ar technology we've given the
developers a brand new version of the
bose ar sdk and unity plugin it allows
unity developers to easily add rosear
integration to community-based apps
they've built a very intuitive
system for our developers like me to be
able to just pop an immunity and just go
we give you access to all of the sensors
that are available in the device the
accelerometer the gyroscope two
different rotation sensors they provide
orientation of the user's head and world
space we can actually provide
spatialized audio which just gives you
an entirely new level of context when
you're making any sort of experience
we're able to get all sorts of different
types of information from the frames
glasses which we can use to help develop
new types of interactions we were
challenged to create an augmented
reality experience that put audio first
it's very interesting to look at games
from like a whole different angle
usually people think ar they go it's all
visual and this one it's both so it's
audio the challenge really made us put
our heads together and be like what can
you really do there's a whole world of
sound and we shouldn't just be paying
attention to just the visual components
so we've had a lot of really creative
ideas that the developers have come up
with so far and i think some of the more
interesting aspects are the different
game mechanics or the user interface
experiments that they're doing the game
we created we're calling sonic samurai
you're the samurai and you can't see but
there are all these monsters around you
and you basically have to use
the bose headset to determine where the
monsters are and then you actually use
your mobile device as your sword to
strike at the monsters
it's a game where you essentially try to
dodge bullets that are sent from one
user towards you
imagine the matrix but you can't see the
bullets that are coming at you you can
only hear them
our game is called overheard you play a
medieval catapult operator catapulting
poultry and cows at french castles
you're doing this all at night under
cover of darkness so you have to use
your ears to hear where the castle is
when you point your frames in the
correct direction you can hear the
french defenders taunting you daring you
to throw things at them your efforts are
always the perfectly good livestocks
by turning your head and elevating it up
you actually modulate the angle that the
catapult will fire at
you are being bombarded by vegetables in
a 360 degree radius you can tell what
direction the vegetables are coming from
based on spatial audio and i you need to
find and face the correct vegetable and
eat it
we're working on kind of a spy thriller
game when you put on those frames you
start to get radio chatter from secret
agents you start doing instructions to
locate radar pings the fuse bombs like
james bond and mission possible in real
life
augmented reality is really one of the
most important future mediums for design
we're getting the tools set up in a way
that allow people to start experimenting
and using something like unity allows
that iteration to happen very very
quickly it's an honor to be chosen to be
here to work on this technology for the
first time and also give developers a
bigger idea of like what's possible with
this stuff so that they can use our
games as like a stepping stone for
what's next
here we are at pax east 2019
all five of these games are debuting for
the first time anywhere people are
having a lot of fun here this weekend
lots of people dodging vegetables and
throwing cows i always enjoy like
finding new games that are animated i've
never played anything just based
entirely on sound i don't think i've
seen anything else here that relies
completely on audio and motion no visual
at all but it felt really immersive and
cool people are really getting a sense
that the audio is like real spatial you
feel like you're really there
it's just a whole different experience
it's more social it really brings us
back to where games really are where
it's with other people it's a fun ride
on these classes we're changing the
landscape of ar and games in america and
this is just a taste of what's to come
that's very exciting for us to have that
chance to impact other people's lives
with a new technology the things that
people are able to do over a weekend
really inspired me to think we're going
to see some amazing stuff this year
we have actually seen some some pretty
amazing stuff this year i feel like
the more of these experiences get built
and the more kind of developers get
creative with it
you know it's an early platform so
there's plenty of room to kind of like
set set the standard at what what could
be created
um
so what else do i have here um yes so
i have a few um actual like gameplay
footage that i'd like to show you on
some experiences that i personally like
um developers cut up these videos to
kind of show what what the games are
like so just gonna get into these again
just some some more inspiration
the worst grim reaper soul mates is an
ar music t-shirt in which a singing grim
reaper plays a song that responds to you
and your world
grim reaper sebastian is a character
from another one of our games
he's tired of his dead-end job
collecting souls and wants to pursue his
dream of being a songwriter
seeking inspiration sebastian asks you
to let him write a song about your life
[Music]
you were looking out maybe lost
[Music]
there's magic in almost every place
[Music]
would you like to share your thoughts
with me
[Music]
wanting to learn about the inside of the
human skull
i ask what's going on in your soul
okay
um
[Music]
humankind okay so if it's not spaghetti
or chocolate cake is it maybe the fact
that the sun will suddenly explode and
everything we know will go up in the
ocean of flames
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
we imagine players using this app while
commuting exploring or just relaxing
through interacting with sebastian and
his song we want to show players that
even the smallest things in life can
carry meaning sometimes we just need
someone to talk to
cool right uh it actually works it's
actually it's actually really fun
so
one of the things that i personally
um have learned over over doing some of
these jams and seeing what developers
uh build is that
when you're not focusing so much on the
visuals
you have a lot of room for story and and
substance if i if i could say so myself
it's like uh this developer
uh it was we had all teams of four so
three of those people were were just
content creators so one was brought as
midi he was he was actually producing
music during the gym
one was just doing like the singing and
the voice acting um i forgot what the
third guy was doing i think he was doing
like ui even though you do still you
know i do recommend to have nice
polished ui
but it doesn't have to be crazy that's
the thing like most games that are very
3d and
one of the things is that's that's a
problem i'm a game developer myself
nowadays there's so many tools and so
many things you can do it's kind of hard
to like figure out what you want to do
because you're like oh my god that's
just overwhelmed with you know
all these all these things that our
modern devices can do
um so
there's a lot of room for for this kind
of content to be produced so this is
kind of like a little ai kind of like
companion game you could say and yeah a
response and there's other things he
didn't mention in the video like it
actually changes based on the weather so
actually checks the weather if it's a
rainy day you start the game he'll have
like a rainy day mood you know if it's a
sunny day he'll have a sunny day mood so
it's kind of like it's a replayable
thing and i don't expect people to be
running this app like non-stop but you i
could probably see people running this
for that one hour of their commute
during the day or maybe like for their
lunch break or something like that which
is actually a lot in terms of like
mobile mobile app usage um you know so
it's fun and it's music so you're you
know you're probably already listening
to music why not have like a soundtrack
to your life for example that's kind of
the idea behind the game
this one
uh is also like a really cool
example so i'll just go let him explain
it that is about popping and grouping
your head to the music
similar to other rhythm games you score
points by staying on the beat
at the moment we have about a dozen
custom written songs
in the future we want the possibility
for players to download hundreds of
songs or play with their own music
library
[Music]
we're going to play party the washing
machine
our foxy friend here is grooving along
as well
you could follow it and he helped you
stay on the beat
the line below is showing your head
movements it also changes colors to
indicate how well you're doing
we really intend this game to be a phone
and pocket experience
we added both audio and tactile feedback
for example the high pass filter turns
on when you're doing bad
and your phone vibrates with the beat
when you're doing great
so the idea of hip-hop hero came from us
wanted to make a game that helped
naturally play with the bose ar devices
something you can play while competing
on the train in public
yeah it's like um
i'll play on words of guitar hero kind
of you know you're kind of staying on
the beat you get rated
based on how well you did how well on
the beat you stayed and you don't have
to have a specific head gesture it's
just kind of like how you would normally
bob your head and they have a pretty
good algorithm for detecting that change
they're using both the accelerometer and
the gyro but i'm not i'm not 100 sure on
that um but yeah i mean it's uh i
thought it was great how they visualized
it as well so that's an actual like
graph based on your your head movement
and then you get rated and you know
it's
yeah you've probably seen games like
this
and this this is the last one this one i
like uh because
you're kind of producing music in a way
now it's it's it's basically song loops
that they've created but
the amount of song loops that are in
this app for example
i mean i'm
someone here can probably do the the
mathematical permutations of how many
combinations of unique songs you can get
out of it but it's a lot um when you
when you include like 10 loops for
example
for you know
bass lines
as you're kind of adding complexity to a
song and if you have like you know maybe
like 10 of each samples and in the end
you have like maybe like 40 samples in
total you could be creating unique music
on every play through choose your own
adventure musical experience of layering
songs set in a world where flowers
produce music
players listen explore and yarn along to
the music collecting song loops like
palm in order to blossom a musical
garden
the game is played by looking around to
find new sounds then nodding your head
along to the beat when you find when you
like
this process can go on indefinitely
allowing players to explore the
countless new ways of layering together
song tracks
it's basically she totally nailed the
explanation like in the beginning um but
basically yeah it's like you look around
you hear a preview of a loop you like it
you nod it and then and you go on and
you're just layering loops and and it it
works really well i mean the developer
really figured out a way to make it you
know if you've ever tried to make music
sometimes you could just mess up and it
just sounds terrible because you're
mixing way too many dissonant sounds
but
they managed to figure out an algorithm
to
layer it and it always sounds good and i
i've tried to break it whenever i play
in these experiences i'm like pressing
everywhere and nodding to everything
trying to to
make it sound bad and i couldn't it
always sounded good so super cool
so that's our developer portal it's
developer.bose.com forward slash bosear
um that's where you'll find the sdk i'm
sure most of you have already gone on
here and downloaded it
but i'll show you where all that is in a
sec
and uh the other the last kind of like
but not least um important thing that i
wanted to say so we have a new program
that we just launched recently and
that's bozear certification so what
bozear certification is is say you build
a bozear app
and you submit it for certification our
internal team will actually help you get
across the finish line and publish the
app to the app store or the android
store making sure you have all the right
requirements and then if it does get
certified it's in within our brand
guidelines which again will kind of help
you get through that finish line
you can get a possible feature on the
bose music app or the bose connect app
and you might even get featured on the
bose website so
it's a really great showcase and a
really great way to get noticed
especially as like a early kind of like
game developer
it's it's an early platform so obviously
you know we're looking for great content
to feature on our portals and if the
content's great and it's again it passes
certification which all these games that
i've shown you they're all in the
process of of getting certified and all
be like available when you have you know
your your frames for example when you
hook them up in the bose connect app
there's actually a section there bozear
enabled apps and then you click that and
there's a directory there of apps yes
this works right now so it works on
android as well yes it does um we had a
little bit of a like
earlier start with ios sdk so so a lot
of stuff was mainly ios
yeah now we're rectifying that there's
going to be a lot of android experiences
coming out sadly it's still you know
some developers just build for ios and
we kind of have to prob them like hey
could you also build an android build
and um sometimes they need to be
incentivized to do that other times they
just do it if it's unity then you know
most of these experiences are going to
be on both
um but sadly that's just kind of how
native app development is they sometimes
just want to work in one and not the
other
but
we are fully android supported now as
well
um yeah and then we also have like a get
inspired page
this is a place where we have some case
studies written um golf shots there if
you want to read about it dead drop
desperado's also up there i think
overheard and it's just kind of like a
little interview with the developers
they kind of talk about their process of
developing and you know
it's a good place to get inspired and
give me like this guy really happy like
ah
[Laughter]
the uh yeah that's that's the basically
the intro uh hope that didn't take too
long um but yeah i just wanted to kind
of give you a little bit of an
understanding of of what this is
um so does anyone have any questions
for
nope cool
all right so now that we've gone through
that uh what i'm gonna do here i'm just
gonna close my unity and uh
let's go ahead and actually fire up
unity and we're gonna get like our
little beginner workshop started
so
you should all have a copy of the
unity package
of the bozear sdk for unity
which you can find it
on our downloads page let me know if you
have trouble finding that we're going to
be using this 4.0.1 beta
when you download that it's just a unity
package it gets downloaded
so i'm just going to let everyone kind
of like get to that
and
the version of unity that i'm going to
be using is just the latest one
i have
2019.2.5
f1
um and i have android and ios build
support
as modules in it
and i recommend that you you know if
you're going to be building to mobile
that you have your
desired platform modules installed
um
i'm just going to let everyone
go ahead and do that
it's always it's always a thing yeah
yeah it's just apple and iphone
but again if you if you don't get a
chance to build
you'll still be able to preview the app
and play with it directly from your
laptop so that's you know for for most
of this workshop we're actually going to
be sticking to the creative side of
things and and concept and trying to
build an experience and then like i said
towards the end we'll we'll try to make
sure that everyone has built um and if
you don't have the right device i'm sure
we have some extra devices and
if it comes to it and you know we could
we could potentially also build or maybe
share devices if needed um but once you
have it set up once then you're good to
go
i have my iphone here
i usually have to have both
all right everyone got their their sdk
and ready to go
so what we're going to do is we're going
to actually make a new project in unity
and
i'll just make sure everyone has this
before we do that
there we go
i'm just going to do the latest and i'm
just going to call this project mit
bose ar unity workshop
and i'm just going to pick 3d project
and create
bless you
yes it
is yeah i think i just missed a little
bit in the beginning
all right
so i'm just going to switch to the
default layout here
so
anyone not have their unity new unity
project open yet
all right just
take your time
well good thing the internet's fast
how old what what's the version
that's fine yeah it's fine i'm
downloading the new one anything that's
past the the lts the
2017.1.4 should be fine anything with
like an f at the end of it it's final
now beta is should work okay
if for whatever reason it doesn't
i know sometimes there's been some some
edge cases but
it should be fine
yes
but i'm sticking to it
so when you do have this um
i just want you to take that unity
package that was downloaded
and just click it
or double click it to open it and you'll
get an import dialog
and i just want you to import the entire
thing into your project
everyone imported
just you should just be able to double
click the unity package and it should
just pull up unity if for whatever
reason that doesn't work you can always
right click in your project here and
then import package custom package that
also works as a backup
instead
oh yeah um
don't worry about that
everyone imported ready to go
give it another minute
so yeah when you import the unity
package you get the entirety of the sdk
um there's samples in here sample scenes
there's a lot of cool stuff in here that
i'll get into and the setup itself is
actually really straightforward and
simple we've tried to make this like as
easy as possible to either put into a
new project or integrate with an
existing project
so if you're familiar with unity or if
you've worked on a unity project before
you'll find that a lot of the um
the
i guess the the the user flow and the
way that the sdk works is is typical
kind of like to to a unity workflow
um
so
once you're all imported
you'll see these three folders show up
so the first one that i want you to look
at is the bose folder if you go inside
the bose folder there's wearable and
then inside wearable there's modules
you go to modules and the first module
that we want is connection so we're
going to go to connection
and then prefabs all right so that's
bose
wearable modules connection prefabs
and i want you to pull in this first
prefab that's available here
uh so just drag that into your scene
and you should see this this white
rectangle pop up now the first thing
that i like to do um
when i start like a unity project
especially if i'm developing on mobile
is i like to pull my game view which is
usually up here
you might have a different layout and i
actually like to take the game view and
i like to make it visible so i actually
drag that game view
over here to the right side of the
project panel so i always kind of have a
little preview window here of of what
the
what my preview looks like basically so
if you go ahead and do that
then you'll see that
the panel that we just pulled in
actually shows up here so
and i'll explain what the wearable
connect panel does it's basically
the entire menu that shows up that that
you can browse all available devices you
click a device and you connect to it um
so
this handles all of the the connection
for you there's some cool features on
here like
auto reconnect and and such so for
example if
during your app for exam maybe bluetooth
connection turns off or or for whatever
reason the battery runs out this panel
will pop up again it'll say you've been
disconnected you know searching for a
device
to kind of like keep the
user experience clean
so
you have the wearable connect ui panel
and the next thing that we actually need
to make the wearable connect ui panel
work is we need an event system
so what i want you to do is i actually
want you to just create an empty game
object
somewhere in the scene
and call it event system
okay
and on that empty game object i'm going
to add component here in the inspector
and i'm just going to start typing event
system
there it is it's a built-in unity thing
and once you have your event system
there's a button there called add
default input modules so just click that
now explain what this does
this actually allows you
to click the ui
of the connect panel now the reason why
we do this separate is maybe you have an
already existing unity project and maybe
you already have your own event system
that you've set up so we don't want to
mess with that but
since we're starting a new project we're
going to create this event system and
add the default input modules like i
said that just allows you to actually
click the ui and and select the panel
so that's pretty much it the last piece
that we need to actually um
set up like our entire bose ar is we
actually go in and we're going to create
another empty object
and
we're going to call this one wearable
control
now what this will do this will actually
stream the sensor data back and forth
from our app so wearable control and i'm
going to add component now if you clear
the search here i'm just going to show
you where the bose components are so
when you clear the search there is a
bose subcategory here and you can click
bose
wearable and we have some sample scripts
here that you can use so the one that we
want is wearable control
we're just going to click that
now
one other useful thing that we added
semi-recently is uh
you can actually go up into
let's see here it's
yeah so if you go to asset
for assets
create
and then there's a bose wearable
category and there's an app intent
profile
so
i'm actually going to take that app
intent profile
i'm going to put that like in my top
directory and and assets because i was
in the in the prefabs folder here
you don't have to but it's just cleaner
that way
and what you'll see here on the right is
you'll actually see the sensors that are
available to us
so for this first app that we're
building um we just need the gyroscope
so i'm gonna check the gyroscope on here
and rotation sixth off
and then the update interval i'm gonna
make it uh let's say 40 milliseconds
that's all we kind of need
in terms of sensors and what this
basically does is it just kind of syncs
up
what what the app requirements are and
what what the app is going to be using
so
back to our wearable control that we
created earlier
you'll see there's a active app intent
profile
empty
slot right here you can actually just
click that and just pull in that app
intent profile that we just created
so again that's uh app intent profile is
in assets create
bose wearable app intent profile
in the app intent profile you want to
select gyroscope rotation sixth off and
40 milliseconds
and then in wearable control
just you know put that app intent
profile there
the last step to get this to actually
work
is where it says here you see it says
editor default provider it says debug
provider
we're actually going to switch that to
usb provider
and what that will actually allow us to
do is we'll actually allow us to send
the data over usb bridge directly to
unity which is great for debugging um
while you're developing so that's
actually what we're going to be doing
first
so
your wearable control has a usb provider
and that's pretty much it so your app
will actually now connect both using usb
and if you built this to android or ios
you'll actually be able to pair with
bluetooth the only problem is is we're
not getting any of the sensor data so
we're not actually doing anything with
it yet
so
the first thing that i want to do is
let's say i just want to uh visualize
like the head orientation like on the
screen so how do we do that right
so what we're going to do here is i
actually want you to go
back to the modules
and in here there's another folder
called model loader
and prefabs so if you go to bose
wearable modules model loader prefabs in
here you'll actually see we have a 3d
model
of all of our bose ar enabled wearables
which is actually really cool
and then there's also a default
for if it doesn't know or maybe for a
future product or something like that so
the wearable model loader actually pulls
up the appropriate model automatically
so it knows which one you're doing but
right now let's just do it manually so
pull up the one that you have so i have
rondos here
so i'm just going to take the rondos
prefab i'm just going to drag it into my
scene
and if i double click it you'll see it's
very small
so i would recommend to scale it up
let's say to something like 40 by 40 by
40.
so we just have our roundels like that
in the scene
and
the last thing that i want to do is on
this prefab i actually want to add
component
and in here we're going to go to bose
wearable and then there's a script
called rotation matcher
so we're going to select that
and we're going to make the update
interval 40 milliseconds
okay
so what rotation matcher does is what
the name implies it'll match the
rotation of the wearable so it'll
actually take the gyroscope data
um and that's actually pretty much it so
this should already work so what we're
going to do is we're actually going to
test it out so i want you to do is i
want you to take your
frames
hook them up with usb to your computer
if you're on windows you'll hear like
the connected sound
and i'm actually just going to maximize
on play here so you can see what i'm
doing i'm going to press play
it's the picker is there i have my
frames i select it in the ui
it's going to connect to it
and there are my frames
tracking
the rotation
as intended
this is all happening over usb so
the cable disconnects yep
it will stop
so the idea is that this is for for
development you're obviously going to be
using the cable but if you took this app
and actually built it to your phone it
would work over bluetooth
so
i want everyone to just get to this
point
and then we'll move on to the next part
and what's really cool about this is
we're already pretty much you know just
a few steps away from doing spatial
audio now that we have the head
orientation
we can actually move our point of
reference for the listener
it should be plug and play yeah um does
it work for you
so
make sure you have um
the wearable control
script
so you you skip this step so there is uh
you have to have the wearable control
script
so what you want to do is you want to
create an empty game object
yeah wearable control there is um
oh so event system
yeah so on press play
so
yeah stop the app
and then add default input modules there
you go now you can press play
and
you should be able to click the ui this
time
so yeah there it is um so let's then try
let's try to update i mean it might be
faster just to swap it with another
program it's i think it's it's something
that we've also
been
been kind of told to do is like people
should know how to how to update the
firmware so if for whatever reason um
it's just not
working
um
chances are sometimes that you just need
the latest
update so where you find that is if you
just look up bose updater like if you
just google it
there's a it's
btu.bose.com
um
just try to follow those steps it's
usually pretty fast
you just download the little little tool
and it's all through through online so
you just have it hooked up
and it'll pick it up so if i try it on
mine here
so
it looks like this i'm gonna connect my
frames
i see it it sees it there's an update
ready for my product and that's and you
just click update now and it'll do it
like in in a minute um if you're just
working you don't have to do that
um but if for whatever reason it doesn't
that's usually the problem has like an
old version of the firmware
um if you need to know how to turn them
off you you actually just flip them
upside down and you put them on the
table and they'll turn off after a few
seconds
bless you
if you get the um
filled connection
uh usually reconnecting the device works
it's it's just a usb debugger thing
yes
so
i'm actually playing the sound
through my bose frame so when you
connect
over usb you can actually drive the
audio also through usb now on mac
you'll see it pop up like in your sound
settings and on windows it's like in the
bottom right in the sound
sound devices you can set like the the
bose frames as your as your default
audio device
so it's a great way to preview with now
what i did here is um
i placed the sound on this sphere
now this sphere is kind of like just in
the middle of my field of view here but
uh
in the next exercise i'm going to
actually kind of show you how to how to
spatialize that sound so you can hear it
so i'm just going to wait for everyone
to make sure that everyone's got this so
far yes all right
so what we're going to do here
there's a couple of ways to do this
but
so typically like your camera
is your frame of reference for
audio so as your camera turns
if you have 3d sounds in the scene
it's going to take the frame of
reference
from your camera
um
to spatialize sound right so what we
want to do here is i'm just going to
actually take
the camera that's staring at the glasses
now that you don't have to do it like
this there's a few different ways to do
it but we'll just do it for simplicity's
sake
we'll take the main camera and we'll
pull them into our frames now the way i
have my scene set up is my frames are
just at
at like zero zero zero and they're scale
40 and the camera is kind of like right
behind them
like that so i'm just going to take the
main camera and parent it
to the frames so it's kind of like
inside the frames
and if i press play i'll show you what
that looks like
so
now if you're turning this is kind of
like this is your frame of reference so
this kind of simulates
your orientation in space basically
right so here's how this is going to
work right so in unity doing spatial
audio is actually really really
straightforward so what i want you to do
is and i already did this i'm just going
to delete it so i can show you how i did
it um it's very straightforward so now
let me
what does it come in there we go
so what we're gonna do
is i'm just gonna use uh a sphere to
represent a sound object just for visual
sake
um so i'm actually gonna
create a new game object so 3d object
sphere
and you know i'm gonna place it at zero
zero zero
and i'm gonna add component to the
sphere and i'm gonna add an audio source
okay so that's a built-in unity thing
now i take this sphere
and let's say this one i'm gonna put it
in front of the glasses like here
okay
maybe a little bit further
and oops and the audio source in audio
clip if you click here um there's a few
different
just sound samples that we have in our
sdk
you could pick like chord lp or
something
it's up to you which one you want to
pick this is just just for the demo
um so we're going to pick a sound effect
we put it in front
and the only thing you got to change is
make it loop so there's a little loop
check mark here so the sound is you know
when it finishes it'll start from the
beginning again
and then there's a
drop down here called 3d sound settings
i don't know if you see that we'll get
to that in a second but the only one we
want to change is right here you see
spatial blend
okay
so i'm actually going to drag spatial
blend from 2d to 3d and that's all you
need to do to turn
audio source into a 3d audio source now
you'll notice that there's
cool things here like there's actually
like the range of the sound that you can
tweak and stuff so we don't have to do
any of that just yet um we can just kind
of leave it as is just make sure it's 3d
and that you have a looping sound effect
and that's all i want you to do right
now so now
if you press play
and you let it connect mine is failed
connecting if that ever happens to you
again it's just it's a known bug that we
have with usb
just
reconnect make sure you know you're
always saving your scene
so you know no crashing happens unity
tends to do that sometimes but you know
rarely but usually it doesn't um so yeah
if you get the failed connecting thing
just reconnect and then try again
so
again so i'm gonna unpress play
i'm gonna reconnect
it's something to do with that it
remembers the previous device and
there's a there's a little bug with with
the usb in that
and connected
so
so
when i turn my head
i can kind of hear
that sphere in front of me
and when i turn this way i hear it here
now i hear it on the left
so in order to get that make sure you're
driving your audio through the bose
frames which on mac you go into the
sound settings here
and on windows i can also show you like
in the bottom right in the where the
volume mixer is
if if it's saying that connecting to
pixel 2
go into the bose connect app and to the
the settings and you can actually remove
any previous device that was there so it
doesn't always do that auto thing
so there is a little bit of a like a
doppler effect i don't know if you can
kind of tell when you're doing that
right so these are all things you can
actually change
here in the in the 3d sound settings so
i think if you just turn off the doppler
it won't do that
i think
so yeah um if you just go into 3d sound
settings and you turn off the doppler
you won't get that kind of like warp
effect when your head turns
um that is an interesting effect that
can be played with
but again this is just the the built-in
um unity spatial audio we actually have
a couple of different ways you can do
spatial audio
so
we've gotten to the to the point where
you've set up
your device you've gotten a little bit
of an intro you've seen what what the
platform is about and this is basically
uh a first example of spatializing audio
right so now as an exercise what i'd
like you to do for for the next 30
minutes or so or maybe even you know
maybe let's say 20 minutes um go online
find some sound samples
set up your own little spatial
soundscape around you
and uh
let's see how that goes
yeah make something cool later you can
get some beach sounds maybe like water
crashing on the side
birds chirping or it could be music
samples maybe you get a drum loop
um i can show you a few like i like
freesound.org is cool
i believe it's resound.org
yeah
uh you need to make an account but it's
free and you know it's all like um free
sounds
there's also a decent amount of like um
websites that offer like loops if you
want if you're going for like a more
musical approach so yeah go ahead and do
that and let me know if you have any
questions i'll be you know going around
and helping you out
you